fin da piccola mi è stato detto di avere
delle grandi
opportunità davanti a me questo grazie
alla mia famiglia mio padre ha creato
un'azienda che oggi una bella realtà
della provincia di salerno che esporta
in tutto il mondo se non avessi avuto un
papà imprenditore non è detto che oggi
sarei a mia volta un imprenditrice e con
ancor meno probabilita un'imprenditrice
nel mio settore azienda metalmeccanica
con prodotti destinati al mercato delle
grandi opere dell'ingegneria civile
praticamente le fiere del mio settore
sono l'unico posto al mondo dove non c'è
fila al bagno delle donne a quello degli
uomini si se non avessi avuto questa
opportunità
un'azienda da guidare non è detto che
oggi lavorerei a salerno la gran parte
delle ragazze e dei ragazzi laureati in
ingegneria come me lasciano la mia terra
in effetti oltre ad avere avuto
l'opportunità o poi scelto ho voluto
coglierla questo è stato possibile
perché sono cresciuta in una famiglia
che mi ha insegnato a pensare che
potessi fare tutto ciò che volevo
impegnandomi un compagno di viaggio che
mi ha sempre incoraggiata e sostenuta e
occasioni di crescita di consapevolezza
che hanno creato le condizioni perché
cogliessi questa opportunità insomma ho
avuto l'opportunità e l'ho colta ed oggi
sono qua
quest ultima opportunità l'invito alte
ed ex l'ho colta nonostante non ami
particolarmente parlare in pubblico e
tanto meno la telecamera perché il tema
dell'inclusione e mi sta molto a cuore
in particolare il tema dell'inclusione
di genere per me alla mia quotidianità
come donna imprenditrice in un settore a
prevalenza maschile
quando si pensa alla parola imprenditore
ci si crea un'aspettativa nel mio
settore generalmente ci si aspetta che
l'imprenditore sia maschio è intorno ai
50 trovarsi di fronte una giovane donna
come mi spiazza e più e mi porta
automaticamente nel migliore dei casi ad
affrontare la naturale diffidenza
causata proprio dal disallineamento tra
aspettative e realtà
a quel punto ho l'obbligo di dover
dimostrare il mio valore per poi
eventualmente essere realmente asportata
ciò comporta uno sforzo costante da
parte mia in termini di tempo e di
impegno con annessa frustrazione nei
casi peggiori nonostante gli sforzi mi è
capitato di trovare chiusura o
addirittura approcci e modi di
relazionarsi discriminatori e spiacevoli
l'aspettativa si crea sulle occorrenze
ossia il numero di volte che accade di
trovare una donna un uomo un giovane un
anziano e così via in un determinato
contesto a ricoprire un determinato
ruolo dove normalmente intendo nel senso
probabilistico del termine non sia
abituati a trovarlo e così mi sono
convinta che per iniziare a risolvere il
problema si può lavorare sulle
occorrenze si può fare in modo da essere
di più siamo troppo poche così ho deciso
di dare un contributo per fare in modo
che ciò inizia ad accadere come
moltiplicando nella mia azienda alle
occorrenze creando delle opportunità ho
impostato una people strategy che
preveda la creazione di opportunità per
entrambi in generi sempre sia in tema di
recruiting che in tema di percorsi di
carriera a tutti i livelli non solo
quello degli uffici
credo fortemente che la presenza e la
convivenza delle diversità in azienda e
mi riferisco non solo a quella di genere
tre possibilità di crescita per tutti e
da imprenditrice ho sperimentato che
crescita personale e professionale
viaggiano insieme le grandi aziende da
anni si adoperano per questo e vale
anche per le piccole come la mia che
vogliono crescere essere competitive e
sane sia in termini di performance che
di contesto aziendale
non nascondo che un tipo di approccio di
questo tipo è sicuramente impegnativo in
termini economici ed organizzativi per
un'azienda come la mia che a 25 anni di
vita nasce da un'impostazione familiare
e dove il percorso di manager
realizzazione è ancora in fieri creare
delle opportunità da noi e costoso
perché nella gran parte dei casi
significa fare spazio appunto creare uno
spazio dove prima non
c'era e faccio un esempio abbiamo aperto
le porte all'inserimento di operai e
nella nostra officina prima costituita
di sugli operai per renderlo possibile
abbiamo dovuto realizzare uno
spogliatoio non esistevano spogliatoio
per le donne
ciò ha comportato dei costi ovvio ciò
che però è stato più costoso e chi
lavora in un'azienda lo sa è stato
creare lo spazio nelle teste delle
persone a tutti i livelli
dall'officina ai livelli manageriali
perché una scelta di questo tipo appare
this economica e con un valore aggiunto
intangibile e di lungo periodo non
semplice da trasferire e far comprendere
alla fine ci siamo riusciti
è con grande orgoglio da parte mi
aggiungo che ci siamo riusciti a farlo
in maniera condivisa
questo delle operaie è uno degli esempi
ma costi e sforzi sono stati sostenuti
essi sostengono per creare percorsi di
carriera che prevedono le stesse
possibilità per donne e uomini nelle
diverse funzioni dalla commerciale alla
risorse umane alla finanziaria da due
anni iniziato questo progetto
stiamo andando avanti step by step
sperimentando e facendo apprendimento ad
ogni passo in questo tempo ho capito una
cosa importante che inizialmente ammetto
avevo sottovalutato creare delle
opportunità non è sufficiente sapete
quante ragazze si sono candidate per il
ruolo di operai e nella nostra officina
metalmeccanica si contano su una mano
mentre abbiamo circa 20 applications al
giorno da parte di ragazzi sapete quante
hanno portato avanti il percorso di
sviluppo nel ruolo sales che avevo
promosso nessuna e possa andare avanti
creare delle opportunità non basta non è
sufficiente la moglie di una persona che
conosco mi ha chiamata dicendo rossella
vorrei candidarmi per il loro dio per
aria
ma mio marito non vuole non basta c'è da
cambiare a livello culturale e sociale
per far sì che ci si senta confidenti
anche solo a prendere in considerazione
l'idea
e a di cogliere un'opportunità un'altra
ragazza mi ha detto che non avrebbe
potuto candidarsi per quella posizione
perché non avrebbe saputo a chi lasciare
i suoi bambini troppo spesso sono
impedimenti pratici e strutturali figli
di un sistema che segue le regole di cui
sopra che come una calamita
contribuiscono a trattenere le persone
dall'agire il cambiamento
così dopo questi episodi e questa presa
di coscienza mi sono detta bisogna fare
di più da imprenditrice sono quindi
passate ai fatti o riprogettato
l'azienda da zero anche fisicamente
intendo pensando di destinare gli spazi
della nuova struttura
la nuova sede della mia azienda appunto
a questo scopo a questa causa
usando ciò che ho appreso come criterio
per le mie scelte contribuendo così a
creare le condizioni per aprire gli
orizzonti la mente e migliorare la
qualità della vita
a questo scopo stiamo realizzando una
sala polifunzionale e un con working
luoghi aperti all'esterno dove sarà
possibile condividere esperienze anche
molto lontane da quelle quotidiane per
nutrire elementi ed aprire il cuore
stiamo realizzando degli spazi destinati
al welfare in particolare ho progettato
l'apertura di un asilo opportunità
principalmente per le persone
dell'azienda ma aperto anche alle e
aicon workers e al territorio tutto
ritengo sia un passo importante sia
pratico che simbolico per arginare uno
mi rendo conto ma da qualche parte
bisognerà pure cominciare degli
impedimenti concreti al cambiamento
tutto ciò costituisce il processo
avviato ma attualmente in atto con il
quale sto dando il mio contributo al
cambiamento
una realizzazione fattiva il tema
dell'inclusione è un tema molto
importante a livello globale sono stati
fatti passi avanti e se ne fanno
quotidianamente ma ancora c'è tanto da
fare su questo tutti facilmente sarete
d'accordo io ho scelto di realizzare
qualcosa in modo concreto
di mettere a terra delle azioni parlare
è importantissimo ma fare lo è
altrettanto il comportamento che un
imprenditore a è quello che conta creare
opportunità e fare ciò che è in mio
potere perché siano colte e la migliore
approssimazione tra ciò che voglio è ciò
che posso fare è il mio modo di
contribuire a cambiare ciò che non mi
piace di questo mondo fare quello che
mio potere perché mia figlia e mio
figlio trovi in un mondo migliore di
quello che ho trovato io